most of the time i pick my own cases but
occasionally someone will give me a case
and it interests me enough to where i
want to see if i can solve it just to
challenge myself such was the case today
guys i'm in the studio
at night it's 1am where i am right now
and how to basic the most mysterious man
on youtube reached out to me talking
about the post malone and weakened music
video
asking any way you can figure out how
much they got paid for this and what
he's referencing is this music video
where they promote something called moon
pay as they buy board apes now obviously
this has to be paid and it got me
thinking i also would love to know now
traditionally these deals would be
private but now with crypto i don't
think a lot of these guys are aware that
it's all just basically out there i
decided i wanted to look to see if we
could find out for ourselves how much
someone like post malone and an a-lister
uh star
gets for something like this so
blatantly shilling a crypto in the
middle of his you know music video with
the weekend how much do you have to pay
someone for that kind of exposure well
when i took the case i wasn't sure i'd
be able to figure out and i just want to
walk you guys through my process of
thinking so we can figure this out
together let's jump into it
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio i'm your host
coffee zilla the internet detective and
i wasn't sure i'd be able to do this one
guys so let's start with what we know
let's bring down the board let's watch
the video a little bit right
let's see what we're looking at here
here it is the new music video from none
other than post malone
and right away we see that something is
different because there he is oh we're
being cool oh but look at that what's
that post has his phone out and he looks
like he's buying a board ape which is an
nft
on something called moon pay which i've
never heard of now obviously this was
paid for but the question is how do we
find out how much they got paid well the
easiest way to do it is to find these
guys uh wallet addresses and hunt down
to see if they've gotten any
suspiciously large transactions around
the time of this music video dropping
now we already have a clue i don't know
if you can see it yet um this right here
the nft he's buying on moon pay right
away this is a unique collectible and if
we find out who owns it if they actually
bought it
you know in the music video we don't
know but if they actually bought it
that's a good place to start to find out
where post malone's wallet is so to
start out we're going to go to open c
and we're going to find the board apes
project and now the thing we're going to
do we can't go through all of these
there's 10 000 of these
instead we're just gonna try to sort
through these with the picture we have
here already it's an eight with a cowboy
hat on on a gray background and the eyes
are bored now this has already narrowed
the field quite considerably but none of
these are exactly what they had in the
music video if we enhance their the skin
is like this zombie color and so when we
sort by that we find nothing
okay so it looks like maybe it's a dead
end maybe they really didn't buy that
nft but if they didn't buy that how can
we find out what they did buy well this
is generally where i just look around
for news articles whatever to see if
these guys have ever posted about nfts
and because influencers can't help
whenever they buy something expensive to
talk about it it turns out that yes post
malone actually did buy a board ape just
not the one that was shown in the music
video
similar this is the zombie thing but
it's on a blue background and sure
enough we find it right away now if we
take a look at its uh history here it
has been bought recently by this account
right here now right away i'm suspecting
this is probably post malone but we have
to check further so we'll go to his
ether scan account to see if he's had
any suspiciously large transactions
recently that might be from moonpay and
so here we are at ether scan we plugged
in uh this guy's address that we suspect
is post malone but uh now all we need
for confirmation is just whether you
know they got a large transaction around
this time so i'm looking around i'm
looking around and
moonpay
moonpay.eth
is paying this person which again if you
remember is literally the brand he's
promoting in his music video so i think
we got the right guy and how much are
they paying him drum roll please
how much does it cost to get post malone
and the weeknd to buy an nft with your
platform
the answer is apparently 175
ether that's right in two transactions
post malone or the wallet we believe
belongs to post malone got paid 175
ether which is equivalent to a little
over 750
000
or three quarters of a million dollars
that's how much it costs to get one of
these a-listers to talk about your put
you in their music video and buy
something on your platform now i'll tell
you guys right away i already looked for
the weekend side of the payment i
couldn't find anything my guess is
either he got paid in cash or because
it's post malone's music video maybe he
paid for everything and just uh he did
the deal right maybe it's just a clap
like that i have no idea but um i was
ready to ship off my answer to how to
basic and wrap up this case but i i you
know one thing was just tickling the
back of my mind i just had a curiosity
how many seconds did this thing appear
on this music video this moon pay i
wanted to know how much does 750 000 buy
in terms of ad time
actually how long does it appear on the
screen and how does it compare to
something like a super bowl ad in terms
of cost to get someone like post malone
to promote you on his like hottest new
music video versus like just like a
super bowl ad so for comparison guys i
ran the numbers on a 30 second super
bowl ad and it costs
183 thousand dollars per second for a 30
second commercial guys now in comparison
we're gonna compare this to post malone
and we're gonna time how long this uh
moon pay is on screen and see if they
should have just bought a super bowl
commercial let's watch together ready
as soon as i see it on okay i'm starting
the timer
i'm stopping the timer that was six
seconds uh 5.85 seconds actually so if
we plug that into our calculator we get
a 134
000
only slightly cheaper than the super
bowl ad i mean just a little bit more
baby and your your prime time i mean i
know these crypto guys are competing for
all the biggest influencers to promote
them right now but i wonder if this is
actually going to pay off for them or
not i don't know i guess only time will
tell but anyways i hope you enjoyed that
guys i hope this was a lesson in how
public the blockchain is it took me
about i don't know at 10 actual minutes
when looking this stuff up on my own to
find all this out i was happy to solve
this little case for how to basic and i
hope you guys learned something about
how you can do an investigation of your
own thank you for watching that's
basically it see in the next one
[Music]
but things will be different if i was
balling